[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Give me
a minute, and I'll
show you how Cloud Storage
can help you store objects
while optimizing the
performance of your apps.
Google Cloud Storage is a
global, secure, and scalable
object or blob store for
mutable, unstructured data,
such as images,
videos, and documents.
When you're building
an app, you store
objects in buckets, which are
associated with a project.
You can then upload objects to
the bucket and download objects
from it using the console
or gsutil commands.
By default, data at
rest is encrypted,
and you have options to secure
it with your own encryption
keys.
You can grant permission to
specific members in teams
or make the objects fully
public for mobile and web
applications.
When creating buckets,
you have options
depending on budget,
availability, and access
frequency.
Choose Standard Regional
or Multi-regional buckets
for high performance,
frequent access,
and highest
availability, Nearline
for once-a-month
access, Coldline
for less than once a
quarter, and Archive for data
that you want to
put away for years.
The objects are
automatically versioned.
And with Object
Lifecycle Management,
you can automatically transition
the data to lower cost storage
classes when it
reaches a certain age
or when you store a newer
version of the file.
Once you have stored
the data, accessing it
is easy with a single API call
for all the storage classes.
Cloud Storage is optimal to use
for hosting static websites,
streaming, and
storing documents.
It's widely used for
backups and archives.
And it is a great data-like
choice for Big Data and ML.
Next time you are thinking about
storing data, take a minute
and look at cloud storage.
For more info, check out
Cloud.google.com/storage.